schönen guten tag wir melden uns mit zdf
heute live und wir schauen direkt nach
großbritannien denn da ist wie day
vecsey nation de also impftag die briten
haben mit der impfung gegen das corona
virus begonnen
und wenn wir jetzt sehen das ist
margaret kennen sie ist 90 jahre alt und
sie hat heute morgen um genau 7 uhr 31
als erste den impfstoff von biontech
pfizer bekommen games forderte in einem
krankenhaus im britischen coventry und
sie hat gesagt dass sie echt froh ist
und sich freut
im nächsten jahr ihre familie und ihre
freunde wiedersehen zu können
denn dieses jahr sei sie eben einfach
die meiste zeit allein gewesen
tja das wünschen sich wohl die meisten
von uns dass wir wieder unbeschwert
andere treffen können und der anfang vom
ende dieser pandemie endlich eingeläutet
wird wir wollen sprechen mit unserem
korrespondenten andreas stamm in london
er wird uns erzählen wie diese gewaltige
impfaktion denn ablaufen soll die so
viele millionen menschen betrifft
und dann reden wir noch mit dem cdu
europaabgeordneten und arzt peter liese
und er wird uns erzählen warum er von
dem weg den großbritannien geht nicht so
ganz überzeugt ist und warum er das eu
verfahren besser findet natürlich sind
wir angewiesen auf eure fragen eure
kommentare die wollen wir haben die
könnt ihr stellen entweder hier unten
ihr seht die adresse
das ist zdf heute live at zdf.de oder
ihr schreibt einfach in die
kommentarspalten rein damit nach london
guten morgen andreas stamm
guten morgen es ist noch vor mittag hier
bei uns eigentlich auch genau
mittagszeit
andreas du stehst vor dem sind thomas
hausmittel wie ist denn die stimmung im
land kannst du das mal beschreiben jetzt
wo es endlich mit dem impfen losgeht
ja das ist ein tolles hinter mir ist ja
eines der 70 krankenhäuser an dem
geimpft wird seit heute morgen wir haben
ja mark keenan schon gesehen und
insgesamt ist das natürlich schon sehr
viel hoffnung begleitet das man einfach
jetzt wirklich das tal durchschritten
hat denn im gegensatz zu deutschland die
in der ersten pandemiewelle ja doch sehr
gut irgendwie davon kamen hat das hier
tiefe spuren hinterlassen auch die
zweite welle es gibt immer noch jeden
tag 400 bis 600 tote insgesamt 62.000
sind es fast und das hat tiefe wunden
hier gerissen und dementsprechend sind
die leute einfach er ist hoffnungsvoll
und sagen okay lasst uns jetzt positiv
in die zukunft blicken ja wir wissen das
dauert noch aber das ist ein großer tag
vecsey nation davy day das ist nicht
ohne grund angelehnt an die großen
anderen die days der wie ebay der
victory in europe day der sieg im
zweiten weltkrieg in europa der dj der
sieg über die japaner im pazifik das
sind also große tage da wird bewusst
mitgespielt und ich glaube das trifft
auch auf das was die meisten hier in
großbritannien heute denken wir sprechen
gleich weiter du hast uns einen beitrag
darüber gemacht wie diese riesige
impfaktion am heute morgen angelaufene
es sind schon zu machen
tief durchatmen ein historischer moment
mit der 90 jährigen mark keenan beginnt
das größte impfprogrammen der britischen
geschichte keine bedenken habe sie wohl
der erste einsatz des vakzins am morgen
nur durch eine notfall zulassung möglich
ist wenn ich das kann dann doch jeder
lasst euch immer es kostet nichts und
ist das beste was je passiert ist
priorität genießen über 80-jährige
mitarbeiter im gesundheits und
pflegebereich die größte hürde nur bei
mindestens minus 70 grad hält das maxim
länger das verhindert bislang geplante
impfungen direkt in pflegeheimen
großbritannien hat impfstoff für 400.000
menschen erhalten für jeweils zwei dosen
im abstand von drei wochen eine woche
danach soll der volle schutz bestehen
ein schutzschild auch für den premier
besuch in einem der 70 im krankenhäuser
im land nach harter kritik an johnsons
kurs in der pandemie nach bislang fast
62.000 toten spricht er vom wendepunkt
im kampf gegen korona und mahnte wir
dürfen trotzdem nicht unachtsam werden
das ist meine botschaft aber es ist
fantastisch dass ein impfstoff da ist
eine gewaltige spritze in den arm der
gesamten nation 4 millionen dosen des
impfstoffs sollen bis ende des jahres
geliefert werden andere vakzine stehen
vor der zulassung licht am ende des
tunnels und hoffnung für margret
schienen nach einem jahr voller
isolation und einsamkeit bald wieder
freunde und familie in die arme
schließen zu können
[Applaus]
andreas kritiker warfen der britischen
regierung jetzt vor dass sie mit dieser
schnellen notfall zulassung auch ein
stück weit von der wirklich schlimmen
bilanz der pandemie in großbritannien
ablenken will was da dran ist natürlich
den zusammenhang den man gerne so
postulieren kann aber dann natürlich
schwer herzustellen ist es kommt nicht
ungelegen
das muss man schon sagen denn natürlich
neben den vielen toten ist es auch die
wirtschaft die wie keine andere in
europa gelitten hat man rechnet mit
einem minus von mehr als elf prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts das ist ein schlag
den es so noch nie gegeben hat und
insofern ist die hoffnung groß dass man
mit den impfstoffen nicht nur mit dem
impfstoff von kaiser bei und heck
sondern auch den anderen die man auch in
hundert millionen facher ausfertigung
gestellt hat dass man dadurch durch die
krise kommt und boris johnson hat ja
eine verheerende niederlage erlebt
letzte woche da hat er nur mit der hilfe
der opposition
die neuen beschränkungen die aktuell in
england gelten durch bekommen und das
war ein warnhinweis es heißt er braucht
luft zum atmen und die hoffte hat er
hofft er dass das vakzin dass die
impfstoffe dass diese impfkampagne ihm
diese luft zum atmen bringt und wer es
stehen jetzt insgesamt erst mal 800 1000
impfdosen zur verfügung und spricht
damit können dann 400.000 menschen
geimpft werden weil jeder braucht er
zwei spritzen damit den impfschutz hat
wie sind denn diese ersten impf
kandidaten jetzt überhaupt ausgewählt
worden
nun eine prioritätenliste gestellt die
ist ganz klar erstmal die älteren über
80 die natürlich am meisten gefährdet
sind und dann wollte man eigentlich in
die pflegeheime reingehen dort das
personal und die bewohner das klappt
erst mal nicht aus logistischen gründen
aber insofern aber auch dort wird man
versuchen eben so zu sagen zumindest mal
die mitarbeiter zu impfen und natürlich
das medizinische personal das natürlich
mit corona an erster stelle zu kämpfen
hat und hatte und das reicht natürlich
bei weitem nicht es ist ein anfang aber
es geht los viele andere impfstoffe
stehen kurz vor der zulassung da hat
großbritannien auch einiges bestellt und
sozusagen das ist heute der kick off auf
für einen langen weg
wir kriegen eine frage rein von don
nation oder so ähnlich auf youtube der
fragt wieso sehe ich nicht wie der
premier die spritze bekommt boris
johnson gilt eben nicht als oben in der
prioritätenliste er ist nicht mal 60 und
hat eben deshalb keinen anspruch
momentan außerdem hat er ja corona schon
gab derart ins im thomas hospital wo er
heute morgen war hinter mir dort hat er
um sein leben gekämpft
man hat damals die vorbereitungen für
sein ableben getroffen so zu sagen dass
die regierungsgeschäfte weiter gehen
können und das heißt es erstmal obwohl
man das nicht mit absoluter sicherheit
weiß aber er ist jetzt eben erstmal
geschützt vielleicht auch nicht aber er
gehört definitiv nicht zur prioritäten
gruppe die jetzt als erstes dran kommen
deswegen des boris johnson jetzt nicht
dran
wie ist die stimmung im land was denken
denn die briten generell über das impfen
die ist da die haltung in großbritannien
ja die jüngste umfragen sagen dass zwei
drittel sich auf jeden fall oder sehr
wahrscheinlich impfen lassen wollen
zehn prozent sind unentschieden er und
der rest ungefähr ein viertel ist da im
moment noch sehr skeptisch natürlich
auch weil man immer man sagt man hat das
hier im notfall verfahren zugelassen das
ging alles sehr schnell
die zuständige arzneimittelbehörde sagt
wir sind unabhängig wir haben das auf
herz und nieren geprüft wir werden keine
briten keine briten irgendwelchen
gefahren aussetzen aber natürlich hat
das ein bisschen skepsis auch gespürt
aber insgesamt es ist glaube ich doch so
dass die meisten briten sich werden
impfen lassen wenn sie dann an der reihe
sind
andreas gehen wir noch mal kurz über die
luft
sie ist ja wirklich enorm schon allein
weil dieser impfstoff von bayern texter
bei minus 70 grad gelagert werden muss
kannst du mal beschreiben wie der nach
großbritannien kommt wieder gelagert
wird wie der gesichert wird wer verteilt
wird ja also die ersten chargen kamen
durch den eurotunnel also per zug aus
belgien dort ist die große produkt
produktionsstätte produktionsstätte von
bayern tag und pfizer und dann wird er
im land verteilt es muss halt immer
darauf geachtet werden dass er bei minus
70 grad oder noch kälter gelagert wird
und die kühlkette darf eigentlich nur
vier mal unterbrochen werden also
viermal darf der impfstoff
temperaturveränderungen ausgesetzt
werden dann sonst ist er dann nicht mehr
brauchbar und das macht es unglaublich
schwierig es hat das angedeutet man
wollte eigentlich direkt in die
pflegeheime gehen dort die bewohner
impfen das hat man erstmal vertagt weil
man das einfach im moment noch nicht
hinkriegt dann macht man sich viel
gedanken drum
aber es ist eben ein impfstoff der der
sehr kalte temperaturen braucht und das
ist etwas hinderlich da hofft man dann
eben auf den oxford impfstoff wie er
genannt wird von astrazeneca und der
oxford university entwickelt der kann
man im kühlschrank und bei viel viel
viel höheren temperaturen transportieren
darauf hofft man dann für 20 21 damit
fielen dank andreas wir werden weiter
gespannt nach großbritannien schauen wir
jetzt ein paar wochen vorsprung habt wie
die impfungen bei euch laufen lankische
bis bald ist ja und es gibt einen ganz
entscheidenden grund warum die briten
jetzt schon mit dem impfen anfangen
konnten werden wir darüber gesprochen
bei denen wurde der impfstoff eben über
eine notfall zulassung zugelassen und
bei uns ist das eben noch nicht so weil
es bei uns ein anderes
zulassungsverfahren gibt das läuft über
die eu und wie das funktioniert erklärt
uns jetzt nochmal stefanie graß kleine
fläschchen viel hoffnung drin
großbritannien hat mit seiner notfall
zulassung ein verfahren gewählt das
grundsätzlich allen eu ländern also auch
deutschland zur verfügung gestanden
hätte
noch gilt nämlich auch für
großbritannien eigentlich das eu-recht
welche daten für ein schnellverfahren im
krisenfall geprüft werden das können die
staaten selbst entscheiden
allerdings gilt eine solche zulassung da
nur für eine vorher festgelegte gruppe
und nur für eine bestimmte menge an
impfstoff eine generelle vermarktung für
jedermann ist dabei aber ausgeschlossen
deutschland und die anderen eu staaten
haben sich auch deshalb für das thema
verfahren entschieden also die prüfungen
durch die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde qualität sicherheit
und wirksamkeit des impfstoffes werden
nach den richtlinien der kommission
geprüft also einheitlich außerdem kann
hierbei bereits eine bedingte
marktzulassung erfolgen
die überwachung der risiken und auch die
beschaffung des impfstoffs übernimmt die
ema das soll vertrauen für die bürger
schaffen selbst wenn es etwas länger
dauert
darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen mit
dem cdu europaabgeordneten und arzt
peter liese aber elise schön dass sie
zeit für uns hallo
es gibt wohl wirklich kaum jemanden der
nicht so schnell wie möglich raus möchte
aus dieser pandemie der chef vom
robert-koch-institut wieder sagt der
impfstoff ist der game changer was sagen
sie jetzt denen die nicht besonders
glücklich darüber sind dass sie länger
warten müssen als die briten david
zunächst mal freue ich mich auch dass
wir an dem stoff haben es in deutschland
entwickelt worden mit unterstützung der
europäischen union
das ist ein erfolg und ich glaube es ist
richtig die meisten menschen möchten so
schnell wie möglich aus dieser
schrecklichen situation dass wir uns
immer entscheiden müssen zwischen
schweren einschränkungen oder vielen
toten und in deutschland sind wir ja
leider da genau in der mitte
viele tote und einschränkungen also das
muss ein ende haben
aber ich treffe viele menschen die zu
recht fragen ist der impfstoff sicher
und dadurch seit märz immer gesagt wenn
die europäische arzneimittelagentur
hinzu lässt dann habe ich vertrauen da
ist ein sorgfältiges verfahren und das
wird fall verfahren das die briten
anwenden ist halt eigentlich für
impfstoffe nicht vorgesehen
eine nationale ausnahme machen aber ich
würde wirklich raten dass wir jetzt die
zwei drei wochen noch abwarten und das
wird dann ein höheres maß an sicherheit
haben als die briten jetzt haben wir
haben einen kommentar von carsten friese
der schreibt auf facebook der beginn der
impfungen in großbritannien ist eine
politische entscheidung und soll den
menschen auf der insel zeigen dass ohne
eu die briten schnellere entscheidungen
treffen können kann man das so sagen
trifft das so zu ja das ist leider wahr
mit hankook der britische
gesundheitsminister hat ja in der
letzten woche auch gesagt das können wir
nur wegen des drecks it die leiterin der
zulassungsbehörde hat ihm direkt
widersprochen
die briten sind noch an eu-recht
gehalten und die zulassungsbehörde die
ich übrigens für seriös halten aber das
verfahren ist halt nicht das richtige
die leiterin der zulassungsbehörde hat
sofort ihm widersprochen und es ist eben
so dass auch deutschland oder frankreich
das tun könnte wir glauben aber dass wir
mehr sicherheit bekommen wenn wir eine
ordentliche zulassung durch die
europäische arzneimittelagentur bekommen
dann ist die firma in der haftung
erstens ist werden die daten genauer und
mehr daten geprüft und ich glaube es ist
auch gut wenn nicht noch eine behörde
drauf guckt wir haben gute werden in
großbritannien aber auch in schweden in
den niederlanden und in deutschland und
wenn ihr zusammen gucken finden die
vielleicht mehr und können noch
zielgerichteter sagen was jetzt geht und
was vielleicht auch noch nicht silvia
hat eine frage auf facebook sie fragt
wer beobachtet beziehungsweise verfolgt
die auswirkungen der impfung jetzt und
wie wird dieses transparent und
öffentlich kommuniziert also nach dem
eu-recht und ich hoffe die briten machen
das dann auch nicht nur jetzt diesen
monat sondern auch ab dem neuen jahr
wenn sie nicht mehr an eu recht gebunden
sind müssen bei solchen notfall
zulassungen aber auch bei der ema
zulassung sorgfältige nach beobachtungen
durchgeführt werden
denn man muss ja dann schon wen wir ich
rechne nicht mit gravierenden
geschrieben glaube wirklich der
impfstoff ist sicher
ich rede viel mit den zulassungsbehörden
auch mit biontech ich habe wirklich
vertrauen aber man sagt ja so schön
vertrauen ist gut kontrolle ist besser
und deswegen wird in den nächsten
monaten und jahren nach eu-recht sehr
sorgfältig geschaut wie entwickelt sich
das und wenn nebenwirkungen auftauchen
werden ja sofort an die behörden
gemeldet und daraus rückschlüsse gezogen
wir haben noch eine frage zur wirkung da
fragt az auf youtube ist das richtig
dass dieser impfstoff ewig schützen soll
also das wäre das optimale wir wissen es
aber nicht wir kennen ja diese
erkrankung noch nicht mal ein jahr und
es wird eben den beitrag angesprochen ob
boris johnson jetzt immun ist oder nicht
das weiß man halt auch nicht so genau
ich gehe davon aus dass er länger als
ein paar monate schützt aber ob es eine
auffrischung sein muss wie bei tetanus
zum beispiel alle zehn jahre oder
schneller
das können wir im moment noch nicht
sagen fakt ist stand heute zumindest in
deutschland ist die impfung eben noch
nicht da und bis dann so viele geimpft
sind das ist was bringt wird dass er
auch einfach leider noch eine ganze
weile dauern
trotzdem sind die infektionszahlen hoch
die müssen runter und vielleicht man
kann jetzt nicht bis zur impfung warten
was schlagen sie vor vielleicht auch mit
ihrem europäischen blick ja gucken heute
alle nach großbritannien sie schlage vor
dass man mal auf die nachbarinsel guckt
nach irland irland war im oktober was
corona angeht schlimmer dran als
deutschland hat die pro kopf mehr
infektionen und jetzt haben sie weniger
als ein viertel
und die haben es geschafft ohne einen
kompletten lockdown und zwar indem sie
die schulen zu offen gelassen haben aber
ganz klar abstand in der schule gehalten
haben und masken fliegt ab 13
sie haben besuchsverbot auch zu hause
aber man darf erstens menschen besuchen
die sonst vereinsamen also die ältere
dame im film hätte in irland besuch
bekommen können ich glaube man kann das
auch verantworten mit entsprechender
schutzmaske beispielsweise und in irland
gab es nur eine belegung von 25 prozent
im öpnv
zusätzlich musste jeder bei dem das
möglich ist im home office und damit
haben sie es geschafft dass sie das
beste land in europa wenn ich jetzt und
jetzt haben sie fitnessstudios und
restaurants wieder auf und gehen
trotzdem viel entspannter in das
weihnachtsfest als wir und ich glaube
jeder in europa auch wie in deutschland
sollten uns da ein beispiel nehmen mit
gezielten maßnahmen die zwar hart sind
war die aus meiner sicht vertretbar sind
vertretbarer als ein kompletter lockdown
zum beispiel die komplette schließung
von schulen
da kann man das schaffen ja das zeigt
also dass man nicht unbedingt nur nach
asien schauen muss wo ja einige länder
die pandemie mittlerweile ganz gut im
griff haben sondern auch bei den
europäischen nachbarn mal schauen kann
wir haben noch eine frage zum impfstoff
und zwar geht es darum die kinder der
impfstoff ist er bisher zumindest in
europa noch nicht an den kindern
getestet worden
die machen aber wiederum in deutschland
ein sechstel der bevölkerung aus und wie
kann das dann funktionieren dass man
trotzdem eine herdenimmunität erreicht
mit der impfung dass sie etwas bringt ja
das ist ein punkt den ich bei den briten
nicht wirklich überzeugend finde die
meisten daten für diese jüngste studie
von biotech sind bei menschen über 18
erhoben worden
trotzdem haben wir jetzt diese notfall
zulassung ab 16
da gibt es zwar einige daten aus dem
außereuropäischen ausland aber denke da
wir ohnehin zu wenig impfstoff haben die
nächsten monate sollte man da noch
vorsichtig sein aber wie bei jedem
medikament ist es so dass man erst an
der wachsenden erfahrungen sammelt bevor
man kinder untersucht und das muss jetzt
in den nächsten wochen beginnen unter
strengen wissenschaftlichen standards
muss man gucken wie wirkt dieser
impfstoff bei kindern und dann kann man
sie im frühjahr oder im frühsommer in
die impfkampagne einbeziehen
und ich glaube dass der impfstoff auch
für kinder sicher ist aber was ich
glaube das ist nicht entscheidend dass
musste zeit wissenschaftlich untersucht
und dann eben auch von der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur geprüft werden eine
letzte frage nach von max
mustermann auf youtube mit welchen
einschränkungen habe ich dann zu rechnen
wenn ich mich nicht impfen lassen würde
ja also das ist schwer jetzt darüber zu
spekulieren ich denke unser ansatz muss
sein wir haben diese ganzen
einschränkungen nur weil das eine große
gefahr gibt weil wenn wir nichts machen
würden dann würden nicht nur 500
menschen pro tag sterben sondern dann
kann es durchaus sein dass mehrere
tausend menschen pro tag an dieser
krankheit sterben nur deshalb sind
einschränkungen gerechtfertigt und ich
hoffe dass wir sehr schnell zu einer
situation kommen wo wir die
risikogruppen geimpft haben vielleicht
schon im märz april dann kann man vieles
sich wieder erlauben weil dann die
gefahr dass viele menschen sterben wer
viel geringer ist und wenn wir dann zu
herdenimmunität kommen dann kann das
leben wieder ganz normal weitergehen
ich kann das im moment nicht beurteilen
ob es eine zwischenstufe gibt wo zum
beispiel man sagt es wäre jetzt wieder
möglich zum beispiel große feste in
geschlossenen räumen zu machen oder ein
konzert ohne abstand und maske das wäre
aber nur für geimpfte möglich dann muss
man sehr sorgfältig diskutieren wollen
wir das wirklich weiter verbieten und
wir sagen keiner darf das weil sich
einige nicht haben helfen lassen
oder wollen wir dann sagen der
veranstalter hat das recht zu sagen ich
mach das mal hyäne konzept ist mit maske
und abstand war dann meine bienen
konzept wäre dann dass ich nur geimpfte
reinlassen das muss man sehr sorgfältig
diskutieren und ich werde jetzt nicht
bereit zu sagen das darf auf keinen fall
ein veranstalter machen und dann würden
wir ja freiheitseinschränkung vornehmen
und wirtschaftliche verluste
aufoktroyieren die medizinischen nicht
gerechtfertigt sind also dann bitte ich
um eine sorgfältige diskussion ich hoffe
dass wir da nie in diese lage kommen
weil wir einfach sehr schnell zu einer
herdenimmunität kommen
aber wenn das nicht gelingt muss die
diskussion sorgfältig geführt werden
da wird es mit sicherheit in den
nächsten wochen und monaten noch viele
fragen gesprächsbedarf und auch heftige
diskussionen geben
vielen dank herr lese ich darf das sagen
sie haben jetzt direkt den nächsten
video call mit gesundheitsminister
sparen ich nehme an da wir zum ähnliche
fragen gehen ganz genau
ja gut dann wollen wir sie auch gar
nicht länger aufhalten danke
dass sie sich zeit genommen haben das
war ja und damit sagen wir auch danke
für euer interesse eure fragen eure
kommentare und verabschieden wir uns
dass bald hieß